[Music]
foreign
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive in the next half hour
we'll see what's making the headlines
with the HuffPost political editor Kevin
Schofield and a former number 10
speechwriter Acer Bennett
so let's see what's on some of those
front pages for you now
treasons to be cheerful is the headline
in the Metro which describes how Ukraine
is benefiting from the chaos within
Russia after the Wagner group
mercenaries turned on Vladimir Putin's
forces
according to the financial times the
aborted Insurrection has laid bare the
cracks in Putin's Authority
and according to the guardian that's
also the view of the United States
the I meanwhile says Mr Putin has been
remarkably silent since the whole
incident ended
the time says that British officials
have been warned to prepare for the fall
of Putin
the male leads with the breaking news
tonight that Sarah Duchess of York has
been treated for breast cancer
and the success of that treatment is the
top story in the express
the telegraph has an interview with the
Prince of Wales in which William says
his life's work will be to end
homelessness
and Some Like It Hot the star has a
warning to watch out for snakes in the
hot weather
and reminder that by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us and we are joined tonight by
the HuffPost political editor Kevin
Schofield and former number 10 speech
writer ASA Bennett welcome to both the
view let's start with the um front page
of the eye
their headline put in silent on Mutiny
that rocked the Kremlin um and it's it's
quite old that we haven't heard from
President Putin do you not think Kevin
considering his his threats and um his
um calling out of treason from yevgeny
progosian um but now silence
with your right energy sounds from a
progression as well which is also very
unusual in very um
verbose in recent weeks uh with a lot of
criticism of uh the Russian Ministry of
defense and the Kremlin so yeah it does
seem as if there's been some sort of
deal has been done obviously uh to bring
this
um putative coup to a swift end and it
was a pretty
manic Day on on Saturday it went from
beginning to end very very quickly and
yeah you're right I think there's an
awful lot of unanswered questions I
think it is significant that both men
are keeping their own counsel right now
there's still a lot of unanswered
questions as to how or what deal what
the details of the deal how did it end
so so quickly when it looked as though
the Wagner group were on the verge of of
marching on Moscow making incredible
progress throughout the day on Saturday
then suddenly it came to Halt so um so
yeah it's um it's still a very febrile
situation the consensus seems to be on
the front page is that you know this is
a huge blow to Vladimir Putin's
Authority and I've not done there's any
any doubt about that and um yeah it's
still I think as I said started play out
in full this particular incident Alexa
do you agree that this has um severely
weakened President Putin
oh absolutely I mean it's a very febrile
atmosphere now when you look at what's
happening in Russia because yes Putin
seems to then have seen off pagosian
um and reduced pogosian now to some sort
of shallower's former self seeking
practical exiled in Belarus and uh with
the vaginal group effectively being
dismantled the former play thing he
built up effectively this private Army
um now you have them all forcibly being
conscripted into the Russian military
those who did not take part
um they'll be forgiven but then even
then those who did not take part will
still be racist offer percussion for
sort of misleading them giving them
these ideas and
um suddenly they're all now sort of
enemies number one practically pariahs
in the country all all in all though and
the reason I I lay that out though is
I've struggled to see you know when we
talk about oh yes it's you know almost a
deal or some sort of agreement you know
what the deal was it feels a very
one-sided deal
um in a sense that you know only one of
them you know well it was still sitting
very pretty indeed where they are and
perhaps what we're going to see is maybe
this defense minister Sergey shoigu
um gets sort of pushed out
um but then if so the chocolate is then
there's endless conveyor belt of you
know
cronies for Putin who are still gung-ho
about this war so it won't really change
very much yeah there is still a lot of
um speculation about the deal and a lot
that we don't know
um but I was reading that one of the the
conditions that that's thought to have
been is that the defense minister would
be ousted
Kevin
yeah that's straight that appears to him
perhaps have been one of the demands of
the Wagner group
um and he says right you know there's a
suggestion certainly that and
progression is now going to live in
Excel in Belarus
um I mean I would be very nervous if I
were him anyone who tends to speak out
against Vladimir Putin tends to meet a
rather sticky end so um someone who has
um quite openly
um criticized Putin and tried to
effectively overthrow him
um I think has to be particularly
worried about their own personal
security so so yeah um it certainly
isn't over you know as a as
um an incident I think that is still
um they started play out in full I think
but I think the bottom line undoubtedly
is that this is the last thing Vladimir
Putin wanted when he's already having to
deal with the Ukrainian um
counter-offensive and the more time that
he has to deal with internal security
matters
um it means that obviously there's less
time for them to focus on the water
itself in Ukraine so yeah it's it's left
him weakened but as Lisa says he is
still in place it was obviously
speculation on Saturday that he could be
overthrown within hours at one point it
looked like that could potentially be on
the car so he is still in situ but you
know
um he's certainly much weaker than he
was 40 hours ago yes the uh U.S
Secretary of State Anthony blinken
though Acer has said that it's exposed
real cracks in the Russian president's
Authority and uh speaking to what you
were saying before that he has been
severely weakened
completely and I think you have to
remember why and what has led us here
simply put it's you know Putin's
decision to invade Ukraine which he saw
as the sort of almost what would have
been the cherry on the cake of this
Messianic Vision he had of trying to
rebuild a sort of Soviet Union a greater
Russia by retaking the lands he saw as
ancestrally his and and yet it's
backfired painfully monumentally it was
meant to be a war that he thought he
could win in about two days and instead
many more months on it's still dragging
on and you basically finding the Kremlin
has having to cover this up with you
know just pumping out lie after lie in
terms of the casualty numbers being
downgraded trying to inflate the
Ukrainian casualties trying to spread
all sorts of disinformation you know in
the media into lying to their own people
you know lying on the international
stage and you know it it's easy to try
and believe his own stories and so all
in all like he he may think you know
this fake news is you know that he's
winning the war that the Nazis in
Ukraine a complete bilge of course you
know they're being seen off but the
thing is Russia's been humiliated and at
the same time people you know the
Russian Elite they can see this they
could talk privately about this stuff
they would never say it in public
because they won't value their lives
um but then your progression has stuck
his head above the power pet and he's
been the most prominent critic yet so
that's really shaken the foundations of
the system and Kevin the um
U.S Secretary of State Anthony Lincoln
also saying that we haven't seen the
last act and we read that there's an
uneasy quiet in Moscow and security
remains tight and we must remember also
that the the Wagner Fighters they remain
in control of um Russian military sites
absolutely I mean this is the first time
that really the the war since it began
last February uh has basically come to
the gates of Moscow that's the first
time that people in Moscow have had to
confront their own personal safety
um now the mayor of Moscow has given
um everyone in in the city the day off
tomorrow
um and clearly there is an uneasy
feeling in the city you know they were
um starting to
um put up defenses on the outskirts of
Moscow when it looked as though the
Wagner group were going to enter the
city at one stage on Saturday you know
this is unheard of you know this is a
this is hadn't this type of
um internal
um almost on the brink of Civil War I
mean this hasn't happened in decades in
Russia and um puta now really has a job
in his hands already you know as Issa
says the war has not gone to plan to put
it mildly I know he has this internal
descent that he has to try and and
dampen down now he obviously he's been
he's brutally been brutally effective in
doing that in the past and but you know
I think people know will look at his
position as president in a different
light you know he is incredibly
vulnerable
um and um it remains to be seen whether
he has a long-term future in the Kremlin
so yeah it's still um
fascinating from a news point of view a
fascinating story to monitor but what
you have to remember is that even if
putting where to fall that wouldn't be
the end of matters you know this is
still a huge uh hugely powerful nuclear
armed country and you know you wonder
who would then follow
um and take Putin's place so yeah
geopolitically it's it's huge really and
it's um obviously a great concern to
written and other Western allies yes and
still very much a moving and changing
story all the time um hey so let's have
a look at the Metro their headline
treasons to be cheerful
um is there a slight danger that um the
Western take on this story is a bit too
triumphalist do you think
was really interesting here because
um yeah Western politicians like Lincoln
you've just alluded to they've been very
careful with their language and for a
very simple reason because it risks
getting played out across Moscow and
Russian TV and then it risks spinning
and feeding a narrative that Putin and
his team would love to feed that you
know old pagosian is some Lackey or
puppet of the West and he's just been
put up to this and you know been stabbed
on by our brave you know establishment
and all this you know Russia was strong
and all it could have self-perpetuates
and so that's why for example
yeah there's some caution yeah among the
political class at the same time in the
media well I think it's interesting and
the Metro does a sort of pun for this
and it's what it's trying to tie in is
that yes there was this you know the
flash in the pan coup but then also at
the same time Ukraine has recently
launched its counter-offensive and it's
just a fact then that you know if Russia
is having to distract itself trying to
suppress its own private military and uh
you know then and crucially Wagner did
take over rostov
um a key military section uh you know
fueling all sorts of troops again all
sorts of supplies through to the front
line yeah that has all sorts of
disruption
um particularly when you compare
alongside what ukrainians are doing in
their own way to sort of sabotage and
Supply chains feeding Russian forces so
that's why you know people then may
think there's a real wind in the sales
of the Ukrainian Army at the moment
um let's have a look at the guardian and
this story Kevin officials asked if the
late Queen would block evgeny lebedev's
peerage because of concerns he could be
a national security risk over his
father's links to the Putin regime this
is um coming out through a new
documentary
yeah I mean it's quite an extraordinary
story this and it appears that the queen
potentially was put in a rather
invidious position
um by government officials I mean it
would have been absolutely remarkable
and probably I think unprecedented where
the queen or of any Monarch to
um intervene and the honors being
recommended by a prime minister in this
case surprise surprise Boris Johnson in
trouble with his honors list again
um and yeah he put forward again a Labor
Day for a peerage and
um security officials were led to
believe were concerned given his
father's
um KGB past and they saw this as a
potential security threat and Boris
Johnson was insistent and for whatever
reason that he wanted
um libidev in the house Awards
um and there was a clash effectively and
looks like behind the scenes government
officials were were trying to to get the
the late Queen to enter to veto it now
unsurprisingly the decision was taken
that this would be a bad idea
um for the obvious reason that you know
you can't really have the queen or any
head of state
um Monarch getting involved in this type
of political process however it does
show however the the um the the extent
of the concerns that um the security
officials had about Lord Lieber devs as
he has now periods um so yeah a
remarkable story and uh and yeah it just
shows even though he's not no longer in
an MP he certainly can't keep Boris
Johnson out of the headlines no
certainly still making the news but the
the Palace of course um uh refused ASA
we read
yes no they refuse to get involved I
think it's actually Kevin's explanation
about how extraordinary such an
intervention with the band explains
effectively why they didn't get involved
because it had been so very
extraordinary obsessed or precedent like
no other
um you know to have them on I could
effectively picking and choosing and you
know approving or not the peers but then
I think it also speaks to the depth of
concern that was felt that you know
given there were concerns about the
implications of National Security this
fruit you must remember will develop
here that the Russian government has to
approve of because he wants to have uh
you know Baron lebedev of Moscow as well
as his title you know the level of
sensitivity about that went to the very
top
let's move on to the ft and this story
cabin about um Tory MPS with um well
sitting in marginal seats um opting not
to trot out to Westminster but to stay
in their constituencies and um maybe
sway the views of their constituents
yeah well I mean this does make a lot of
sense when you speak to conservative MPS
who actually do make it to Westminster
they're incredibly pessimistic these
days even ones who uh were willing to
give Rishi sunik a chance and thought
that by bringing him in he'd steady the
ship and give the government back its
credibility after let's trust and Boris
Johnson and that would give them a
Fighting Chance at the next election
even those
um people when I speak with them now are
just incredibly pessimistic so you can
understand why conservative MPS might
want to spend more time in their
consistencies especially those who are
you know reasonably marginal seats
because they are really at risk of
losing their seats so they need to get
out on the doorsteps as much as they
possibly can now I'm sure a lot of
Voters however will be thinking to
themselves hang on a minute we pay you
to be in Westminster so why aren't you
there now the reason for that that they
can get away with it is that
um it's a bit of a zombie Parliament
right now
um the order a business each day pretty
much ends very early and there's not a
lot of legislation going through
Parliament so that is why the whips can
afford to in the parlance slip these MPS
so they don't have to be Investments and
it can be as I say out in the doorsteps
trying to drum up support but I wonder
whether it is too early I spoke to 1mp
on on Friday conservative MP who said
the best they can hope for now is just
to try and get as many MPS back as
possible so they can be an effective
opposition after the next election
that's how that's how bad it is for
um conservative MPS right now so yeah as
I said it makes sense that they want to
go out there to do their best to try and
save their seat but I think for a lot of
them I think it'll probably be a bit too
late
ASA we've only got about 20 seconds and
tell us about Elton John and his
Farewell concert tonight
well I mean I was just watching on other
channels before coming on and ah what
what a guy absolutely right the kindest
thing about him at the moment was that
the Stars he was bringing on their new
Talent he's giving them a leg up while
he's passing the torch on
Elton John passing the tool show on
there well summed up Acer and Kevin
thank you very much